[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
dimanche en politique sur france 3
bourgogne le 17 juin 2017 les électeurs
envoyé à l'assemblée nationale leurs
nouveaux députés il y a donc tout juste
un an l'assemblée changeait de visage
dans le sillage de l'élection d'
emmanuel macron de nombreux députés
faisaient leur entrée pour la première
fois au palais bourbon l'échiquier
politique a également été largement
bouleversé
un an plus tard comment nos députés
ont-ils travaillé comme on conçoivent
t-il leur mission d'élus de la
république sont ils épuisé par le rythme
législatif de cette première année at il
une évolution dans la pratique politique
et le nouveau monde annoncée par
emmanuel macron est il vraiment en
marchant dans des bars ce dimanche matin
en direct sur france 3 avec didier paris
ce début loué la république en marche de
côte-d'or bonjour merci d'être là en
direct didier paris savant de de parler
à aux députés qui sont en face de vous
comment vous vous avez vécu cette
première année en amont première viendra
très bien c'est une année dense
politiquement avec beaucoup de contenu
et qui doit donner à nos concitoyens de
sentiments qu'enfin les choses bougent
et donc les parlementaires jouent
pleinement leur rôle en la matière alors
on va y revenir bien sûr largement dans
un instant josiane corneloup bonjour
députés les républiques à de saône et
loire pour vous comment s'est passée
cette année sachant que c'est comme pour
viser parisse votre premier mandat de
député
très bien je pense qu'effectivement il a
fallu un certain temps pour prendre ses
marques
mais très rapidement nous avons enfin
moi personnellement j'ai à la fois pu
conjuguer le travail législatif le
travail en circonscription et je trouve
que j'ai réussi à trouver un équilibre
qui aujourd'hui me satisfait cécile
untermaier bonjour bon je vous êtes
député nouvelle gauche on dit hein c'est
le groupe du parti socialiste et
apparentés à l'assemblée nationale et
vous êtes évidemment député de saône et
loire vous pour vous comment s'est
passée cette première année elle s'est
passée très bien aussi enfin s'agissant
de moi évidemment elle sait pas si bien
parce que j'ai trouvé mes marques depuis
un certain temps vous avez un point de
comparaison par rapport à vos
collections là c'est notre deuxième en
barrant choquant dans vos
dans vos propos introductif vous parlez
d'une assemblée qui a changé de visage
je dirais oui bien évidemment elle a
changé de visage et c'est tant mieux
en revanche moi je regrette que cette
assemblée n'est pas changé de méthode
mais je pense qu'on y reviendra
bien sûr on va y revenir dans un instant
merci à tous les trois d'avoir accepté
cette invitation en direct ce dimanche
vous qui nous regarde et vous en avez
l'habitude vous pouvez commenter cette
émission sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag dit mme paul bourgogne alors
j'ai envie de vous demander d'abord
comment allez vous mesdames comment
allez-vous il paraît que le rythme est
très soutenu vous avez tous répondu que
l'année s'était bien passé mais est-ce
que vous êtes fatigués on est au mois de
juin fin juin les vacances pour beaucoup
de français arrivent et je leur souhaite
dans l'est dans les jours qui viennent
pour vous ce sera peut-être un peu plus
tard comment allez-vous josiane candelon
écoutez moi je vais bien j'espère que je
ne parlais pas trop fatigués font savoir
en tout cas effectivement le rythme et
danse mais je pense que comme le disait
ma collègue il n'a pas changé de ce
qu'il était dans les lices la thur
précédente
l'étude de loi est toujours la même les
procédures sont les mêmes
certes nous avons eu ces derniers temps
un certain nombre de lois qui sont
arrivées toutes les unes après les
autres de façon très rapprochée
je pense effectivement est la loi
ferroviaire à la loi agricole à l'eau à
la formation la loi immigration donc
évidemment le rythme a été a été plus
dense mais je pense qu'au delà du rythme
ce qu'il faut surtout regarder c'est la
qualité et ça ça me paraît plus
important il faut que nous ayons tout de
même le temps de pouvoir étudier ces
textes correctement de les avoir
suffisamment tôt en amont pour pouvoir
faire les auditions qui sont nécessaires
écouter à la fois nos concitoyens
écouter les associations écouter les
syndicats pour faire un travail qui soit
un travail qui correspondent aux
attentes de nos habitants vous avez
l'impression que ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas
pas toujours pas toujours est ce que
vous partagez ce point de vue du côté de
l'opposition même si vous êtes d'un côté
de l'autre de l'émission sénateurs
maillard oui je pense qu'on partage
qu'on a une culture politique et d'une
manière générale je pense que d'abord je
ne suis pas fatigué je tiens à le
préciser également pas du tout au
contraire
enthousiaste et déterminé dans mon
mandat en revanche peut-être un peu
excédé déçu excédé par la précipitation
avec laquelle les derniers textes sont
venus dans l'hémicycle et au sein de la
commission
le rythme est quasiment le même que
celui du précédent quinquennat dont
conduite aux excès d'épargné la réforme
ferroviaire la loi immigration comme l'a
dit josiane corneloup on a travaillé sur
sur tous les textes sur tous les pans
sur la loi alimente alimentation
agriculture alimentation sur la loi sur
la sncf qui n'est pas rien on a devant
nous la révision constitutionnelle de la
constitution ce n'est pas rien non plus
correctement
je veux faire correctement mon travail
et je veux ce que je ressens surtout
c'est que le pouvoir exécutif est
beaucoup plus puissant qu'il ne l'était
on est entré dans une république qui
n'est pas une république du nouveau
monde une république moderne
nous sommes entrés dans une république
de la centralisation et du jacobinisme
et je pense que les parlementaires que
nous sommes tant à gauche qu'à droite
que à l'assemblée que en marche
nous devons non pas être dans un un
système du ni oui ni non
nous devons être dans un système où nous
avons vraiment notre place et
l'institution assemblée nationale doit
être une institution mature dans
laquelle le débat doit vraiment trouvé
sa place et je pense que ce rythme
peut-être moins bien organisé que dans
le précédent quinquennat
nous avons eu un peu plus fouillis
d'ailleurs c'est ce que c'est l'image
qu'en ont finalement un peu les français
et les citoyens et les personnes qui
vivent sur le territoire
et bien ce rythme la nuit à la
lisibilité de l'action politique et je
crois que il est extrêmement important
pour nous tous quels que soient nos
appartenances politiques de faire en
sorte et bien que l'action politique
soit lisible et qu'elle ait été entendu
par les parlementaires et je donnerai
qu'un exemple en exemple moi qui m'a
fait un peu mal et je me dis on est loin
du nouveau monde c'est par exemple
amendements sur le glyphosate
alors qu'on sait que c'est un débat on
est pour ou on est content on sait les
difficultés pour voter en pleine nuit en
catimini
députés mais il faut arriver je dis pas
que le précédent gouvernement ne leur ai
pas fait ça hélas je pense qu'il
l'aurait fait aussi mais je crois que
nous devons nous en responsabilité
vis-à-vis de nos électeurs organiser le
débat et dans cette somme d'amendements
qui arrive à l'appui d'une loi
identifier les amendements sur lesquels
il y ait un débat et l'organiser on
allait faire passer trois heures du
matin nous les devons à nos électeurs
wayne nous le devons à nos électeurs de
la majorité tranchera mais nous devons
organiser on va laisser répondre didier
paris puisqu'il est là au type de la
majorité déjà
est ce que les députés sont épuisés moi
je sais rien nous n'avons aucun d'entre
nous ici ou ailleurs n'a été élu dans le
sentiment que les choses allaient être
facile simple et naturelle il est
absolument normal que nous travaillons
nous avons été pour ça nous avons été
élus pour que les choses évoluent et
françois de rugy dit le travail est trop
dure il dit même que c'est intenable
d'ailleurs il est d'accord avec jean luc
mélenchon et méchant s'exclame m
changions que nous changions les c'est
un thème que nous abordons sans doute
les procédures les manières de faire la
loi fabrique de la loi il n'y a aucun
doute que là il ya une évolution à faire
mais ce que mon collègue enfin je le dis
en fait le rythme est soutenu et donc on
pourrait par moment ne pas avoir le
temps de faire notre travail
correctement c'est une réalité mais je
pensais pas une réalité d'aujourd'hui
c'est une réalité tout temps ce que je
remarque quand même c'est un nous nous
avons été élus pour travailler le temps
politique est relativement court parce
que tout le monde sait que mag en forme
qui sont pas mises en place cinq ans
mais un temps réel à 2019 2020 2021 déjà
des élections donc on a déjà deux ans
lie fenêtre de tir si vous me permettez
l'expression qui est extrêmement
importante et qui c'est vrai peut donner
que ce sentiment je rejoins c'est signe
quand elle donne cette explication qui
peut donner sentiment de d'un rythme
effréné
cela dit un a plupart des dispositions
que nous votons ont donné lieu à un
dialogue préalable
prenez la loi sur l'alimentation prenez
les ordonnances à sucre il ya eu un vrai
débat citoyen
je sais pas combien de réunions 56
réunion avec les organisations
syndicales sur la loi sur la loi travail
donc nous à nous arrivons à un niveau où
quand même la perception citoyenne est
déjà très importante après c'est vrai
nous avons un rythme qui est qui est
élevé à nous aussi de suis très frappé
mois en une année de voir à quel point
les nouveaux parlementaires veulent est
extrêmement présent à l'assemblée ça a
un côté très positif
sa cote est un peu lourd c'est que vous
et certains textes avec 2000 voire trois
mille amendements 2000 à 3000 à saint
pour préparer la réforme
constitutionnelle absolument loi
organique qui va diminuer tous à une loi
constitutionnelle une et plusieurs lois
organiques des lois ordinaires
il ya d'évidence une évolution du
système à mettre en place pour que enfin
nos modes de travail ne soient pas des
modes
c'est difficile à expliquer parce que
finalement nous on le vit tous les jours
et c'est très con sexe pour le voilà
certains complexes mais ce qu'il faut
juste comprendre c'est que nous avons
beaucoup de discussions redondantes
il peut y avoir jusqu'à treize fois
l'analyse d'un même texte entre les
navettes entre la première lecture le
sauf que c'est qu'il passe pour vous
pour une simplification du côté de
l'opposition josiane corneloup ça passe
pour on veut museler l'opposition
elle vient quelque part je trouve
qu'effectivement l'intensité du travail
est tout à fait présente
nous souhaitons le faire au mieux donc
nous souhaitons avoir le temps d'étudier
ces textes correctement et le nombre
d'amendements que vous évoquez qui est
certes important je crois que dans les
précédentes 17 heures c'était la même
chose
il était aussi important il suffit de
regarder la loi sur le mariage pour tous
sur la loi sur la presse
c'était des lois qui avait été qui avait
fait l'objet de très nombreux
amendements et je crois que il faut être
aussi très vigilants et je rejoins
cécile également lorsqu'elle disait
qu'il ne faut pas arriver à une
centralisation et à une négation du
parlement parce que le fait de diminuer
les amendements c'est tout de même pour
moi une atteinte à la liberté
d'expression est une atteinte à notre
démocratie sauf qu'il ait jamais été
question de diminuer droit d'un moment
où c'est un droit constitutionnel et
aucun problème là dessus c'est nos modes
de train et qui doivent changer c'est
tout à fait l'inversé
est évoquée c'est quand même que
certains articles demain seront étudiés
en commission et d'autres articles
seront étudiés en science publique
c'est-à-dire tout de même être le nombre
d'amendements en fonction de
l'importance du groupe a jamais qu'il a
jamais été question
constitutionnellement limiter le nombre
de mandats rhône serait dans ma collègue
et examen c'est-à-dire il ya des moments
sur certains textes dès lors alors reste
à savoir comment la décision se fera
entre les uns et les autres mais sur
certains textes quand même la redondance
de la discussion et est lourde
alors que on ne fait finalement que
reprendre les mêmes arguments donc quand
c'est possible on doit pouvoir améliorer
le travail en commission au regard de
celui de la séance quand vous quand vous
dites tel tel amendement qui est passé
en pleine nuit oui c'est exact mais il
faut se rendre compte que tout le
travail parlementaire n'est pas
seulement celui qui en séance celui qui
est visible celui qui nous constitue
maintenant franchement vous savez la
gamme derrière la question du glyphosate
elle était match crucial majeur au coeur
de nos recettes loire d c'est une
question importante mais vous ne parlez
pas personne ne parle de la réalité de
ce texte qui est celui de la
restructuration des prix agricoles
attendu d'eux puis les ouates 62 qui est
absolument fondamentale et qu'après on
part glyphosate comme étant un élément
de société importants je ne le conteste
pas mais finalement y compris si on le
regarde de la presse moi ce qui me
surprend beaucoup c'est qu'on ne
s'intéresse qu'à certaines questions qui
sont des questions légitimes en oubliant
tout un débat au sein de votre majorité
sur cette question c'est sam était aussi
en difficulté par moment nicolas hulot
est bon c'est pas son nom mais je le
prenais le glyphosate je le prenais à
titre d'illustration d'une
inorganisation du débat et même d'une
manipulation du débat et nous nous
devons tous ensemble nous les à nous les
députés nous défendre d'un exécutif qui
nous déposent des amendements le jour de
la commission qui nous déposent des
amendements le jour la séance publique
sans étude d'impact ne nous permettant
pas de jouer notre rôle d'éclaireur et
de voter en conscience
donc on a un vrai sujet là dessus moi
sur le nombre d'amendements sur les
trois mille amendements je dis faisons
quand même attention le parlement il est
là pour parlementer
il ne doit pas être vécue comme un
empêcheur de tourner en rond d'un
exécutif qui voudraient travailler
finalement tout seul avec sa haute
administration sauf que dans la
république en marche on vous dit les
français veulent des réformes ils ont
élu une majorité un président la
république pour les mener et si ça prend
trop de temps et bien ils n'en verront
pas les fruits et les attentions les
mages interactions areva attend dé moi
je pense que dans le précédent
quinquennat on a fait autant de réformes
est d'ailleurs là le bilan sera beaucoup
plus positif que ce qu'on a voulu faire
et on sait pourquoi on a une alternance
aussi brutale d'un gouvernement un autre
on a fait des choses importantes le
mariage pour tous était colossal du
point de vue sociétal
on a fait sur le non cumul des mandats
on a fait sur les conflits d'intérêts
avec la haute autorité de la
transparence et de la vie publique par
exemple on a fait sur l'éducation aussi
des choses intéressantes sont à cheval
donné l'impression aux français ils
s'embourbent mais là si vous voulez il
faut donner de la lisibilité politique
et on l'a plus je pense que les français
ne savent plus vraiment où on va on ice
et révision constitutionnelle qui est
majeure qui va organiser le pouvoir qui
qui fondent notre démocratie
et sur ce point là il faut nous donner
du temps et fort heureusement moi je
tiens à saluer l'intervention de richard
ferrand qui a obtenu vous voyez quand
même une semaine de plus pour qu'on
puisse travailler un peu plus
sereinement sur un texte de magie
réforme consensuelle vous avez
l'impression que on est en train d'aller
vers un régime plus présidentiel qui
donne plus de place et de choix les jeux
c'est la cie les présidentielles moi je
connais emmanuel macron je sais que
c'est un démocrate et je ne suis pas
inquiète par rapport à sable en revanche
ce que je redoute c'est que l'assemblée
raked si vous voulez sans le coche qui
est de devenir une institution mature ce
qu'elle n'a pas été non plus dans le
précédent quinquennat - deux députés
c'est bien ou c'est pas bien moins deux
députés - le sénateur c'est pas bien
après en tout cas pour les députés je
pense que c'est pas bien parce que je
pourquoi pas en limiter un peu mais pas
de la manière aussi drastique que celle
ci et je n'en comprends pas l'objectif
parce que en fait un député c'est un
être hybride qui travaille sur deux sur
deux sur deux jambes d'un côté à
l'assemblée nationale de l'autre côté
dans sa circonscription comme l'a dit
d'ailleurs
josiane et comme je sais que le fait
didier on doit faire en sorte penser le
rôle du député élu dans une
circonscription s'il est élu dans une
circonscription il doit travailler avec
les citoyens et moi je considère que la
constitution du 21e siècle c'est une
constitution qui est écologique
il ya une constitution qui est éthique
qui pose le problème du conflit
d'intérêts parce que l'ouverture des
contractuels l'ouverture du champ
contractuel à tout à toutes les
administrations exige exige
effectivement une dimension éthique et
c'est pour ça que nous considérons que
la haute autorité de la transparence de
la vie publique doit avoir un rôle
majeur
mais c'est aussi une constitution qui
fait entrer le citoyen dans le parlement
on n'est pas une bulle l'assemblée n'est
pas une bulle je laisserai pas les
relais de parisse et puis ensuite il y
avait jose est normal ou qui souhaitent
aussi en parler comment dire
nous sommes dans une obligation absolue
c'est de faire que le parlement
l'assemblée et le sénat en lien avec le
l'exécutif souhaite efficace nous avons
un souci d'efficacité
évidemment cette efficacité ne peut pas
se s'exprimer au mépris des règles
élémentaires qui sont celles du rôle du
parlement du rôle du parlement
on parle toujours de la création de la
loi au parlement on parle rarement du
contrôle de l'exécutif qui a absolument
central et passerelle va si bien le
temps absolument et c'est peut-être le
problème il est là au fond c'est il faut
impérativement que nous continuions à a
modifié à modifier les textes pour pour
faire que la france se remet en
mouvement quand c'est cindy il ya eu
beaucoup de réformes oui sans doute ya
beaucoup de volonté de réformes des
réformes effectives efficace j'en suis
moins sûr mais ça n'est pas plus de
nature politique
est ce que le gouvernement doit être
seulement efficace on a l'impression par
moments que emmanuel macron parle du
rôle du parlement un peu comme s'il
parlait d'une entreprise 1 il faut que
ce soit efficient faut que ce soit
efficace
est ce que est ce que c'est vraiment le
rôle premier du parlement
le rôle premier du parlement c'est de
voir suffisamment d'écart par rapport à
la réalité pour pour prendre la hauteur
qui qu'on attend de lui mais en même
temps suffisamment comme l'a dit cécile
je suis d'accord suffisamment la
perception du terrain la perception
concrètes pour éviter des erreurs
évidentes pour autant moi j'insiste il
ya eu déjà beaucoup de textes qui ont
été votées je crois que c'est des textes
qui correspondent absolument à
l'attendre des français et c'est vrai
qu'un besoin de pédagogie c'est à dire
tout va très vite
et derrière une explication est parfois
insuffisante c'est un énorme travail
c'est un énorme travail auquel nous nous
nous attelons et le retour en
circonscription à cette absolue
nécessité c'est de ré expliquer enfin ce
que nous avons fait pourquoi nous le
faisons laissez parler josé alcorta et
ensuite dire un mot sur le travail en se
consacrant regard de votre question sur
le diminution du nombre des députés
je pense la même chose que cécile
aujourd'hui nous avons des
circonscriptions je prends la mienne 145
communes sur notre département de saône
et loire de 5 députés nous allons passer
à deux voire trois ça veut dire que nous
allons avoir demain des circonscriptions
de 300 communes
il me semble qu effectivement le rôle du
parlement c'est d'être à l'écouté de ses
concitoyens
c'est tout de même le peuple qui nous a
élus nous avons une vraie mission et
nous leur devons effectivement une
efficacité donc nous leur devons cette
écoute et cette écoute me paraît
absolument indispensable et moi lorsque
je vais et je vais très souvent dans des
manifestations en circonscription de
toute nature j'entends la tante de nos
concitoyens j'attends une j'entends une
efficacité mais j'entends aussi le
besoin de de disponibilité le besoin de
proximité et avec des circonscriptions
de 300 communes celle ci ne sera plus
possible y compris votre argument mais
certains peut-être ceux qui nous
regardent vont dire ah bah oui mais il
ya surtout laissé députés là ils ont
peur de perdre leurs sièges sinon parce
qu'il n'ya plus que s'il ya plus que
deux ou trois députés dans dans le
département au lieu de cinq hivers en
moins de place oui mais est ce que est
ce qu'on pourrait si vous voulez c'est
pour ça que le dispositif surf sur le
populisme et est donc on est nous dans
une situation de défense corporatiste et
dieu c'est moi si je suis pas
corporatiste et comme j'ai défendu avec
macron la fin du corporatisme dans la
loi de 2015
donc je suis pas dans ce schéma là - le
second souci et je pense que c'est le
souci de nous tous c'est de faire en
sorte que si on est élu au suffrage
universel qu'on a on ait la possibilité
de retourner vers nos électeurs n'ont
pas à la prochaine élection mais pendant
tout tout le temps d'exercice de nous
avions justement vous avez le temps
d'aller dans les circonscriptions en ce
moment vous y êtes là parce qu'avec le
dernier train législatif là on dit que
les députés n'ont pas le temps d'aller
en séries il ya déjà une donnée qui a
été évoqué par par cécile untermaier
c'est que les parlementaires ne sont
plus responsables d'exécutifs vous
n'avez plus de maires présidents de
départements situés donc ce mouvement
avaient déjà été entamés d'une forme de
distance un petit peu qui a été créée au
calme ans après comment dire les
parlementaires ils sont là
essentiellement pour faire un travail
législatif
donc ça suppose effectivement une
présence à paris qui est très importante
qui nous permet un peu moins d'être
présent sur la circonscription
mais ce qui est clair c'est que le rôle
du parlementaire après cette réforme
constitutionnelle si elle va jusqu'au
bout évidemment ce sera un rôle
différent
moi j'ai 2 125 communes dans ma
circonscription
le prochain député d'une circonscription
comme ça il en aura plus de 300 et
probablement 250 millions l'intérieur à
moins de députés à l'assemblée donc pour
les questions là alors les enfants
connaissance et à la question réelle
c'est que moins deux députés sans aucun
doute et moi j'adhère tout à fait à ce
projet parce que je pense que notre rôle
il est de 2 de la fabrique de la loi du
contrôle du gouvernement
l'idée c'est le parlement ne baisse pas
ses moyens on diminue le nombre de
parlementaires au sénat la même chose ne
baisse pas ses moyens mais chaque
parlementaire un rôle à un rôle beaucoup
plus efficace et renforcé dans la
construction de loi dont contrôle du
gouvernement et dans l'évaluation des
politiques publiques
c'est un enjeu majeur y compris des
expertises qui nous manque aujourd'hui
on va laisser répondre l'opposition
josaine corneloup et c'est si longtemps
vient d'un mot parce que j'aimerais
qu'on en vienne aux réformes en cours et
celles qui ont exécuté
je voudrais dire une chose une chose
c'est que cette cette réduction du
nombre de parlementaires a été annoncé
dans un premier temps comme une source
non pas d'économies ce que attendait
peut-être un peu à tort à mon avis des
citoyens
mais comme la possibilité en fait de
mettre plus d'administrateurs à
l'assemblée nationale et permettre à ses
députés de travailler mieux mais on il
faut le dire quand même au peuple que
l'on est en train de les priver d'élus
au profit de hauts fonctionnaires et la
haute administration est actuellement au
pouvoir avec l'exécutif c'est vers cela
que nous sommes extrêmement réservé tout
à l'heure sur cette réforme il ya un
accord pour le parti socialiste et les
républicains lorsque notre collègue dit
le travail du député c'est d'abord un
travail législatif donc d'abord un
travail à paris j'ai envie de vivre de
vous dire oui sauf que lorsque vous
rencontrez les personnes en
circonscription vous êtes dans la vraie
vie vous êtes confrontés aux difficultés
que vous exprime les personnes et c'est
notre rôle de législateur de combler des
vides juridiques sur deux paliers au
niveau de la loi à des
dysfonctionnements et je crois quand
même que ce travail législatif il
découle vraiment dur et elle est
effectivement si c'est pour ce pour
priver le député de lien avec le concret
au profit de fonctionnaires qui vont
être à nos côtés je n'ai rien contre eux
nous en avons besoin
mais je pense que pour la population
c'est quelque chose de très
préjudiciable il lancera pas privé mais
l'organisation et aucun doute
organisations devraient différentes
et contrairement à ce que vous dites
c'est pas des hauts fonctionnaires dont
on aura besoin c'est des assistants
parlementaires qui nous font défaut
aujourd'hui c'est aussi la possibilité
pour le parlement de recourir à une une
logique des expertises indépendantes que
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
en fait la faiblesse du parlement c'est
pas tellement l'exécutif qui leur donne
c'est que le parlement n'a pas les
moyens d'exercer réellement cheyrou je
vais vous réinviter ses premiers pour
une émission sur la réforme du parlement
mais j'aimerais qu'on parle de cette
année il vient de s'écouler nouvelle loi
travail réforme de la smc de la sncf
oui suppression de l'impôt sur la
fortune loisy l'immigration loi élan sur
le logement l'eau agriculture et
alimentation sont autant de sujets qui
ont alimenté les débats et parfois les
polémiques est-ce que vous
né de ses défauts de réformes que vous
avez voté ou non en tous les cas où vous
avez des battus parfois beaucoup josaine
corneloup est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose
qui vous a particulièrement soit choqué
soit plus dense et serrée formule 1 et
12 a le droit la beauté aussi je trouve
qu'effectivement c'est ces lois sont
arrivés de façon très intense et très
dense très rapidement pour certaines
avec peut-être un manque de temps pour
aller en profondeur
en tout cas moi je me suis beaucoup
investi sur la loi agricole parce que
c'est une problématique est très
présente dans ma circonscription
beaucoup également sur leur formation
apprentissage parce que là aussi j'ai
rencontré en circonscription nombreux
chefs d'entreprise qui m'avait
énormément de difficulté etc ce cas et
je trouve que pour un certain nombre
d'entre elles
nous sommes passés à côté du fondement
même de la loi et de l'objectif premier
typiquement la loi agricole alimentation
l'objectif premier c'est est de redonner
du revenu et de valoriser davantage le
produit est bien en fait lorsque vous
regardez la finalité de cette loi nous
avons fait passer un amendement qui vise
à mettre des indicateurs pour définir un
prix qui intègre les coûts de production
nous l'avons passé à trois voies notre
groupe
sans cela il n'y avait rien par rapport
aux prix et c'était l'essentiel tout de
même rapidement même question pour
cécile untermaier et bien moi je
regrette de ne pas avoir voté plus de
loi qui était proposée par la république
en marre j'en ai voté la loi sur la
confiance me paraissait nécessaire même
si je pense qu'on pleure tous maintenant
la réserve parlementaire que l'on
pouvait entourée de garanties parce que
les associations sont en souffrance
actuellement j'ai voté aussi le droit à
l'erreur que j'ai trouvé extrêmement
intéressante et d'ailleurs gérald
darmanin m'a aidé dans ma
circonscription sur un dossier sur le
fondement du droit à l'erreur en
anticipant le texte donc moi je
reconnais bien sûr des avancées tout à
fait intéressante mais là encore je
crois que le débat n'est pas
suffisamment plein et trans partisan est
ce que je ressens actuellement c'est que
la république en marche finalement avec
le en même temps c'est un peu dans le ni
oui ni non et le en même temps il se
fait entre soi alors que le en même
temps ça devrait être aussi la présence
considération d'une opposition qui skie
qui apporte des éléments l'une des
missions les accords parce qu'évidemment
cote comme ces signes dit ni oui ni non
il me semble avoir compris au contraire
qu'on reprochait à l'exécutif et au
parlement actuel de trancher trop vite
et trop fort donc il faudrait savoir on
en est à l'assemblée dit pas les
créatifs lui disent que les deuxième
élément ce que je remarque c'est aucune
loi n'a été votée qu'avec les voix de la
majorité
aucune ya toujours eu les épaules et ses
sens et c'est sain c'est normal il ya la
pikes comme ça vient de dire la
perception de ce qui a selon d'avancé
qu'ils sont fait qu'ils sont réels qui
étaient nécessaires y compris sur les
thèmes de la sécurité qu'on n'a pas
abordé dans
la prorogation d'état d'urgence et suivi
la mise en place du mois sur cyclonique
intéressés merci à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté de répondre à ces
questions et de débattre en direct ce
matin merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
pour ce numéro ce dernier numéro de la
saison on se retrouve bien évidemment à
la rentrée pour de nouveaux débats dans
un instant le point sur l'actualité
régionale avec fabienne acosta suivi de
la partie nationale de dimanche anthony
francis letellier poursuit ce débat en
recevant aurore bergé porte parole du
groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée bon dimanche à tous sur
france 3